[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings where we're
talking about the newest economic battle
between the world's largest economies
that would be the US and China it's
taking place in the sky there's a
state-owned Chinese company that's
developed a passenger jet the c919 to
challenge America's Boeing and Europe's
Airbus Jets now China has never been
able to make anything like a 737 before
now so how'd they do it Chris Van Cleave
has been digging into it it's a CBS News
investigation Chris good morning it's
like something out of a spy novel Good
morning Tony it really is it is a
fascinating story and critics say the
development of this airplane is not only
an effort to Elbow Boeing out of the
huge Chinese market but also to gain
access to U.S technology that could
benefit the Chinese military
foreign
this isn't just a new airliner it's a
growing threat to the U.S economy that's
poised to take off the chinese-built
c919 is so important to the Chinese
Communist party it's been called a
source of national pride Aerospace is
part of the game of Nations John
ostrower editor of the air current has
tracked the progress of the c919 for
years the ability to design an airplane
It ultimately represents self-reliance
modernity the desire to engage with the
world it's been a top strategical for
over a decade a large low-cost domestic
airliner positioning China to one day
capture one of the world's largest
markets for jets potentially costing the
U.S economy up to 1.5 trillion dollars
over the next 20 years I mean you're
talking about a market of about 8 000
airplanes and if China wants a chunk of
that that fundamentally means fewer
airplanes for Boeing an Airbus to
deliver
China unveiled the prototype to much
fanfare and after lengthy delays the
first completed c919 was finally
delivered to a Chinese Airline four
months ago if this national emblem of
China looks a lot like an Airbus A320 or
Boeing 737 that's by Design according to
current and former National Security
officials like Matt pottinger it really
looks like
um a a knockoff 60 percent of the
plane's components are the result of
deals with America's top aerospace
companies China has a lot of different
varieties of ways of relieving people of
their intellectual property the price of
admission to China's lucrative Market is
steep if you want to sell stuff to 1.3
billion people in China you're going to
have to give us the blueprints or for
your goods or you're going to have to go
into a joint venture with us where
you're going to train our engineers and
this is what we call forced technology
transfer the National Security Experts
say there's another way China acquires
American innovation mission Espionage do
you feel like they stole an airliner I
don't feel that way I think that's a
fact bill evanina was America's top
counterintelligence official when the
Department of Justice exposed an
intricate scheme targeting American
Aviation Technology how strong is the
link between Chinese Espionage and the
c919 it's directly related to the
Chinese Communist Party can no longer
say we don't utilize our intelligence
apparatus to conduct economic Espionage
this is now proof that they do and
they've been very successful at it a
2019 crowdstrike report revealed one
major focus of Beijing spycraft
components of the c919 evidence gathered
by U.S investigators and shared with CBS
news shows Chinese intelligence officer
Shu Yan Joon used aliases front
companies and false documents as well as
an intense hacking effort one main
target a GE Aviation engineer who
specialized in jet engine design first
process is what they do all the time
invite them over to China to give a
speech very benign what does he do at GE
what are the types of unclassified
things he's working on shoes requests
grew Bolder catching the attention of
the FBI agents launched a sting
directing the GE employee and listening
to his Communications as they plan to
meet in person again
speaking in Chinese Shu asked him to
bring his company laptop so Shu could
look over the stuff the employee assured
him I certainly will have the computer
two months later Shu traveled to Belgium
to meet the employee but the FBI was
waiting he was brought to the U.S to
stand trial and late last year sentenced
to 20 years for spying it was Monumental
it's the first time ever where we
arrested indicted convicted in a jury
and sentenced a known intelligence
officer running a cell collecting
aviation technology to benefit the
civilian and Military apparatus of the
Communist Party of China shoe sentencing
memo reveals two Chinese state-owned
companies involved in building the c919
were the intended recipients of his
spycraft beijing's goals for its
Aerospace industry it's not to just be
one of a few competitors it is to
dominate the global space and drive its
competitors out of business they not
only want Boeing and Air Airbus out of
China they want them out of business
certainly do you remember Alcatel
Marconi Nortel these are all Western
companies in the space of making
telecommunications equipment those
companies don't exist anymore they're
dead and Airbus and Boeing are on the
kill list now
the c919 could fly its first passengers
in China any day now but it has not been
approved by the FAA so it's not likely
that you will see it at U.S airports in
the foreseeable future notably Boeing
and Airbus declined comment for this
story in a statement GE Aviation
credited its Advanced security systems
and cooperation with the FBI for helping
identify that Chinese spy thank you
Chris good to have you here